hi my name is Eric chain I'm security
and privacy product manager at Google
focused on data deletion
generally speaking Google removes data
in three stages stage one is the
deletion request this is when the user
issues a deletion request either via the
cloud console or via the API and a piece
of data is flat for deletion stage two
is the data removal and recovery once
the deletion request is made the data is
made inaccessible to read requests and
it is hidden from the product user
interface this removal step confirms the
users deletion requests some deletion
requests allow for recovery such as
those for accounts projects or a query
on bigquery Stage three is the deletion
if the data marked for deletion is not
recovered within the stage two window it
is deleted in the underlying layer of
products such as cloud storage or cloud
spanner each CCP service from which data
gets deleted has its own detailed
process to ensure complete deletion this
might involve repeated passes through
the system to confirm all data has been
deleted after the recovery period GCP
will broadcast a deletion request with a
unique account or project identifier to
all sub services this will begin the
product level deletion during which GCP
waits for an acknowledgement signal from
all the products to complete deletion
most of the products will then GCP
performs deletion by overriding this is
done by removing the file pointer to the
data and once the data is marked as
deleted the space it occupied is marked
as empty and eventually overran by new
data Google Cloud Storage goes one step
further by activating cryptographic
erasure which deletes the key that is
used to decrypt the storge buckets
before a deletion of the buckets content
by overriding last but not least let's
not forget decommissioning of Hardware
Google meticulously tracks the location
and status of all equipment within our
data centers through acquisition
installation retirement and destruction
via barcodes and asset tags if a
component fails to pass a performance
test at any point during its life cycle
it is removed from the inventory and
retired when it is retired authorized
individual verify that the disk is
erased by overwriting the drive with
zeros
forming a multi-step verification
process to ensure that the drive
contains no data if the drive cannot be
erased for any reason it is stored
securely until it can be physically
destroyed depending on available
equipment we either crush and deform the
drive or shred the drive into small
pieces
in either case that this is recycled at
a secure facility ensuring that no one
will be able to read data unretired
Google disks to learn more about
deletion on Google cloud platform please
visit our website and read our white
paper thanks for watching